la belle inconnue la femme en bleu c'est
là sa table
[Musique]
la dame en bleu portera désormais le
noir pour michel louvain tout a commencé
au colisée de québec lors du gala des
splendeurs en 1958 il a été propulsé
très rapidement au sommet de la gloire
bonne nuit quatre cas
vite repéré le jeune talent de 20 ans
est invité sur les grands atouts
télévision c'est le nom rappelle michel
louvain il est né à ted friedman rien
n'est laissé au hasard pour en faire une
vedette
même son nom au coin de saint denis un
restaurant qui s'appelait au louvre un
immense en 5
il faisait deux étages de haut ça
m'avait frappé deux semaines après l'
agent qui s'occupe de ma carte
il faut de change dont nombre poulain
c'est pas très artistique je m'appelais
louvain
les femmes ne résisteront pas à son
charme le succès est instantané
c'est la folie il ya même des émeutes
kressley débutait aux états unis les
petites filles cuillère et voyez alves
on arrête cycle et les jeunes filles de
mode du québec avait besoin d'un idole
louvain arrive la première fois qu'il
vit l'état répète tous les enfants du
monde
sylvie louise ou lisons michel louvain
parler directement aux femmes dans ses
chansons lisant
[Musique]
il faut ne s'est pas rue
je veux te dire mais la dame en bleu
restera son plus grand succès il l'a
suivie partout chanterai la dame en bleu
du début afin que le monde sera content
[Musique]
les matériels et humains charles lima
du hameau
[Musique]
oh
la ta
dans les années 80 90 il mène en
parallèle une carrière d'animateur télé
qui lui vaut des prix metrostars est à
vous bublé
merci parce que vous êtes ma force
les honneurs viennent aussi de la dce
avec le félix hommage en 2014 merci à la
douce pour ce bel hommage et je vous dis
57 ans de mercy son public vieillit vécu
main et même en fin de carrière il fait
encore salle comble
la retraite ce n'était pas pour lui ils
s'apprêtaient à repartir en tournée
m
on a
j'ai toujours l'air de sortir de chez
moi à ma mère m'avait téléphoné pour me
dire mon garçon tu es né sous une bonne
étoile
sa bonne étoile aura veillé sur sa
carrière pendant plus d'un demi-siècle
[Musique]
au canada montréal est
[Applaudissements]